I'm Rosaly Lopes I am a senior research
scientist here at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory and I have expertise on
volcanoes on Earth and the planets I'm a
planetary geologist but my specialty of
volcanoes
when we look at volcanoes on earth we
are looking at a limited range of
conditions and you can't very certain
parameters for example a composition of
the volcanoes on earth ears in a limited
range we have a water as the main
volatile like the main gas that comes
out of the magma of course the gravity
is the same everywhere when we look at
other planets you have very different
conditions may be different compositions
or you know at least in some ways and so
if you're studying volcanoes as a
physical system it really helps you to
be able to look at eruptions and
volcanoes on all the worlds and we find
things on other worlds that we wouldn't
have expected to find such as the
volcanoes on Io driven by tidal heating
not plate tectonics and on the icy moons
of the outer solar system we have
cryovolcanoes or ice volcanoes